hello
and welcome to today's talk on the
clinical utility
of concussion injury biomarkers i'm paul
johnson
an associate professor at upstate
medical university
in syracuse new york
before we begin today's presentation i
want to mention that i
have no disclosures either financial or
other conflicts of interest
related to this presentation
three main learning objectives to
discuss with you today
these include identifying current
diagnostic tools for assessment of acute
concussion
or traumatic brain injury tbi
second to describe the clinical utility
of serum biomarker proteins for
detecting concussion injury in human
subjects
and third to discuss serial sampling
strategy and reference change value
to identify a significant change in
biomarker test results
in this first part of my talk i'd like
to begin with brief discussion
of definitions and diagnostic tools
related to
assessment of traumatic brain injury
traumatic brain injury or tbi is a term
applied to various outcomes related to
head injury
which ranges from mild to severe
the most mild form sub concussion injury
is limited to neuropsychological
findings without structural damage
as such these are undetectable by
imaging modalities such as brain ct
or mri scan
as tbi increases in severity
we have concussion injury which is
usually referred to
as mild injury or mild tbi mtbi
this is transient impairment of brain
function associated with injury
imaging tests are also often negative in
many cases of mtbi
acute subdural hematoma or bleeding
within the brain
is the next level of severity
this is observed 75 percent of the time
in moderate to severe concussion injury
by brain ct or mri scanning
and lastly chronic injury from repeated
blows can manifest
as chronic traumatic encephalopathy
or cte
tau and phosphatidyl proteins accumulate
and deposit in the brain
which has been linked to possible
development of cte
many know that cte has gained increased
attention in recent years
especially among contact sports athletes
in professional leagues
this is a neurodegenerative disease
which is irreversible
however for today i'll be focusing on
the first two of these sub concussion
and concussion injury
because these often present the greatest
diagnostic challenges
in addition the hope is that early
diagnosis
may prevent later development of more
severe cases of tbi
next i'd like to briefly highlight the
growing concern
of increased tbi cases the u.s
centers for disease control and
prevention
has reported roughly 2.88 million
cases of tbi
last in 2014 and this is up from 153
million
cases back in 2006
representing a 53 percent increase
in tbi related cases these are those
presenting to emergency department
visits hospitalizations
or resulting in deaths
the most common cases of tbi include
sports injury
combat injury to veterans and military
personnel
accidental falls and motor vehicle
crashes in fact it's been reported that
50 percent of tbi cases were due to
motor vehicle crashes
in a recent paper and jama neurology
nonetheless tbi definitions remain the
same regardless
of the underlying cause
before addressing biomarker testing it
will be helpful to understand
signs symptoms and functional tests
associated with concussion injury
common sides and symptoms include
suggestive
symptoms such as headache or nausea
physical symptoms such as
loss of consciousness loss of memory
vomiting
or neurological conditions such as
behavioral
or emotional changes cognitive
impairment or
sleep disturbances
functional testing or non-biomarker
testing
include neuroimaging cranial
computed tomography or cct scanning
is used to visualize fractures or
lesions in the brain
post injury it is considered to be the
gold standard test
and that to which we'll be comparing
some of our biomarker tests
and magnetic resonance imaging or mri is
also used as one of these
modalities
functional scoring algorithms such as
the glasgow coma scale
gcs or the scat 5 the sports concussion
assessment tool
and balance testing or balance error
scoring system
are also used as functional tests for
assessment of
tbi
the glasgow coma scale is a point system
based on assessment of three criteria
eye response verbal response and motor
response
scores range from 3 to 15 with the
following categories
severe head injury is defined as a gcs
score of 8 or less
moderate head injury with a score of 9
to 12
and finally mild head injury or mtbi
with a gcs score of 13 to 15.
so a person may have a perfect score on
the glasgow coma scale rating but still
have
mild concussion injury
scad 5 or the 5th edition of the sports
concussion assessment tool published in
the british journal of sports medicine
has been also used to evaluate tbi
and this is embraced by several sports
organizations
around the world
it relies on a multi-step approach which
includes the gts score as we just saw
with the i
verbal and motor responses plus certain
red flag
items such as serious neurological or
physiological signs and symptoms
other observable signs such as the
person being knocked out
or motionless facial injury after trauma
and finally cognitive testing memory
assessment questions as well as balance
testing
are integrated into the scat 5 scoring
system
with that introduction in mind i'd like
to now focus attention
in part two on the clinical biomarkers
of acute concussion injury
highlighted here are going to be the
role of the blood-based biomarkers
clinical biomarker tests have been used
to detect multiple causes
of underlying acute brain injury
some clinical examples include
diagnosing brain injury upon cns
infections both
viral and bacterial acute ischemic
stroke
and finally concussion injury or tbi
several different body fluid sample
types have been used during the course
of both clinical
studies as well as diagnostic studies
these include
saliva which is non-invasive but
currently limited in applications
it has been used in molecular profiling
such as
micro rna patterns associated with head
injury
cerebrospinal fluid or csf is the most
direct measure of brain derived proteins
within the central nervous system
however it's a very invasive sample to
collect
finally blood samples or more commonly
serum or plasma
are the most popular sample types to use
for these biomarker test assays
it is a less invasive collection
compared to csf
and as an indirect measure serum can
provide detectable changes
of central nervous system derived
proteins
which qualities make for a good
candidate
tbi biomarker in blood
well in general these are going to be
produced by cells within the brain
region
they'll appear in the peripheral blood
upon head injury usually through
damage to the neuronal cells
and also they need to have a good
detection time window
so these increases will be detectable
soon after injury
and also the elevations will remain
above baseline for several hours to few
days after
injury
thus for these biomarkers the biological
functions
are less critical than the physical
properties of the markers we're going to
be looking at
as such the focus in this presentation
is on commonly studied biomarkers
before we look at those biomarkers
we'll look at one mechanism injury and
release of substances
using proteins into the blood after
concussion injury
often through disruption of the
blood-brain barrier
the blood-brain barrier is formed by
brain endothelial cells
connected by tight junctions
trauma to the head may breach the
protective layer
of the blood-brain barrier
and substances normally produced by
neurons astrocyte cells
glial cells may be released into serum
following head injury
and these are the biomarkers of interest
to us
and once in the peripheral blood these
proteins will transiently spike
in concentration until undergoing normal
elimination
usually through renal mechanisms
for this talk i've included six of the
most popular
serum protein biomarkers used in the
field however in no particular order
this includes markers with approved
clinical use
as well as common research use only
markers
while all of them are immunoassay format
the designs
do differ across manufacturers in terms
of detection
and the way that the system is run some
of these are manual tests
whereas others have become more
automated
the first couple that we'll look at
recently
received fda approval in the united
states for
in-vitro diagnostic use or ibd use
these are uchl1 the ubiquitin
c terminal hydrolase l1 and gfab
gliofibrillary acidic protein
other markers shown here have received
diagnostic approval outside of the
united states
such as s 100 beta the calcium binding
protein s 100
beta iso form has been approved in the
european union
for clinical use both for potential
brain injury or tbi assessment
as well as a role in non-tbi cases such
as malignant melanoma
however in the united states this is
labeled as a research use only
test assay neuron specific enolase or
nse
is also a popular biomarker
this enzyme is usually used to detect
neuroendocrine tumors such as a
neuroblastoma but it's also had
potential clinical use
in tbi cases and concussion injury
myelin basic protein is another popular
protein that is studied as a potential
biomarker for tbi
however the major focus of this is using
csf testing rather than blood testing
and in diagnosing multiple sclerosis
or ms and it's actually received u.s
approval as a lab develop test for
clinical diagnostics for
ms patients and finally
prostaglandin d synthase or beta trace
protein
this has also been a popular marker in
research use only
of tbi clinically it's been used to
detect
csf leakage into the nasal cavity or ear
canal
highlighted in this slide are the
diagnostic performance characteristics
of three in vitro diagnostic approved
biomarkers gfap and uchl1 from
banyan biomarkers out of san diego
california
and the s-100 beta test assay from roche
diagnostics
in europe headquartered in manheim
germany
as we can see from these performance
values
we note that the clinical sensitivity
shown also with the 95 confidence
interval around those estimates
are nearly 100 or perfect for all of
these biomarkers
i should note that the tests gfap and
uchl1 are actually interpreted together
so
these values are identical in both the
first two rows
the s100 beta assay from
roche has also shown to have high
clinical sensitivity
or true positive rate of 98.8 percent
on the other hand the clinical
specificity or true negative rate
is quite low only in the mid 30 percent
range
this is coupled to the negative
predictive value and the positive
predictive value
of negative and positive test results
respectively
notice that the tests with the high
clinical sensitivity
also have very strong negative
predictive values
meaning that a negative test will help
to rule out the diagnosis of tbi
nearly 100 percent in all cases
on the other hand the positive
predictive value meaning
the post-test probability after a
positive
biomarker result is fairly equivocal
because we only have a 9.2 percent
post-test probability
with the first two markers in an eleven
percent post-test probability
with the s-100 so a positive result from
these tests
is not very useful and helpful
clinically
and as we'll see it usually means that
the biomarker would need to have a
follow-up with a ct scan
for diagnosis and i've summarized that
in the table shown here again with the
high clinical sensitivity
high negative predictive value as being
good attributes of these biomarkers
whereas the low
clinical specificity and relatively low
positive predictive value
are not very helpful
so their tests are going to be good at
ruling out the need for ct scan
which can benefit the patient because it
reduces costs in the healthcare system
and also can prevent unneeded radiation
exposure that the patient would need to
undergo
in a publication by papa eddal published
in jama neurology
the authors looked at the temporal
profile of the gfap
and uchl1 biomarkers
they used the banyan biomarker tests
the bti test assay which eventually led
to its ibd
approval from this study
but what we note here looking at the
upper cutoff values that they had
established
in nanograms per ml units shown on the y
axis here
gfap has a very low cutoff upper cutoff
value
and uchl1 also has a
relatively low cutoff value compared to
the spikes and rises that we see in both
of these biomarkers
and notice that there's a sharp rise in
serum levels
in both markers after injury
which return to roughly normal or
baseline levels
after 72 hours so they're rapidly
cleared
by the body usually by renal mechanisms
after they've spiked in this transit
manner so there's a very narrow window
in which we can actually use these
markers to detect
acute concussion injury
in a pilot study colleagues and i had
looked at two serum biomarker tests
the s-100 beta as well as the neuron
specific enolase tests
and a study group of amateur mixed
martial arts fighters
we published information on the study a
few years ago
as an abstract and i have the citation
here for those
interested in reading more about the
study design
of most interests to us were changes at
baseline or pre-fight
to post-fight levels to see the time
course of injury
in a small subset of these individuals
we had also
investigated the temporal changes at
four time points
for both of these markers
specifically we're looking at
pre-fight values labeled as a
these were blood draws taken before
one of the mixed martial arts fights in
time point b
this was 30 minutes after the fight had
concluded
within 30 minutes and then we were able
to resample these same individuals
72 hours later and then one week after
the fight
for this small group of 11 subjects we
noted
in the trend increase in the post fight
within 30 minutes after the fight in
both markers
with return at or near baseline by 72
hours for time point c
and to put these values in perspective
i've shown the clinical cutoffs
recommended by the test manufacturer for
both
s100 beta as well as the neuron specific
enolase
so this final part of the talk we'll
explore the
sample serial sampling strategy with
special attention given to
biological variation and reference
change value
given the limitations of diagnostic test
performance
we've already observed with the high
false positive rates
as previously described meaning the low
clinical specificity
there is hope that a serial sampling
strategy can offer an alternative way to
interpret those test results
to highlight a few selected applications
already in diagnostic use for the serial
sampling strategy
the first is acute myocardial infarction
or
ami detection cardiac troponin test
measured in blood
or serum on a suspected patient
having a heart attack we'll follow a
time course
usually at baseline three hours post
admission
and then six hours post admission to
look for the trend and changes
this is very helpful as a rule in and
rule out strategy for someone with
suspected ami
whether that patient needs to be
admitted to the hospital to the icu for
example
another use of the serial sampling
strategy is to detect
acute kidney injury or aki
this is indicated when the baseline
serum creatinine
value in the patient increases by
0.3 milligram per deciliter or 26.5
micromoles per liter
within the previous 48 hours so we're
looking at
a time course of these markers as the as
they change
and finally the use of the reference
change value or rcv
this aids in post-analytical test
interpretation
and relies on having biological
variation estimates
of the clinical test marker to calculate
the rcv
biological variation these data are
descriptive measures of dispersion
biological variation describes a random
fluctuation of biomarkers
due to normal physiological processes
and this fluctuation occurs around the
subject's mean or average test
concentration value
and it's been termed the homeostatic set
point
at that average test concentration value
measures of dispersion that are used to
describe these data
are variance standard deviation
and percent coefficient of variation or
relative standard deviation
those variance components are separated
out using the analysis of variance or
anova test
and biological variation databases
include information for
a multitude of clinical biomarkers
i've included the links to both of these
databases the first from 2014
on the westgard qc site these are
provided in a table format
and the european federation of
laboratory medicine and clinical
chemistry
has a more updated database from
estimate said in 2019 and these are
searchable by test marker
as well
illustrated in this figure are the two
components of biological variation
i've shown this with an example of the s
100 protein
and the concentration on the y axis in
picograms per
ml the observed variation
of the test result between subjects
is referred to as the cvg the
coefficient of variation
of the between subjects or the group
variants
and the within subject variance
or cvi shown here
so for each one of these subjects that
range will be
the cvi in these 12 subjects
we determine the cvg and cvi estimates
from repeat sampling of healthy
individuals and in this case we're
speaking of non-concussed individuals
and this figure represents eight
separate measurements
from 12 subjects with a plot of the
eight individual values shown in the
gray dots
and the mean value for each
individual shown with the blue dots
and note that all these values are
within the interpretive
range much less than 105 for the upper
cutoff
and the median values were in fact 48
picograms per ml
oh and a subset of subjects having
repeat blood draws
in our study my colleagues and i had
looked at the normal baseline
or pre-fight time point concentrations
in order to calculate
and estimate the within person
biological variation the cvi
for both the s-100 and nse biomarkers
further the rcv or reference change
value calculation
shown in the table was used to calculate
that significant change
cutoff value
of note the rcv provides individual
diagnostic assessment in place of
population based reference interval
cutoffs
so instead of using the 105 cutoff that
i just mentioned for s100
here we're going to be using a
percentage change or
rcv to determine significance
and from those calculations we can see
that a one-sided rcv
gives a significant increase of
44.1 percent or greater for s 100 beta
and 54.1 percent or greater for the nse
protein
in order to determine percentage change
we apply the formula shown here which is
the patient's current result
minus their baseline result divided by
the baseline results
then we ask what is the probability that
the percentage change in the test value
from baseline is significant this can be
determined by comparing to the 95
percent
significance rcv value based on
biological
variation data
the benefit of the rcv is it may allow
for increased detection of positive
results
from 87 paired samples baseline
to post fight we compared the clinical
cut-off values
using the population reference interval
established by the manufacturer
in panel a and compare that to the
percent change significance
based on rcv in panel b
notice for the nse test the percentage
of individuals who went from a pre-fight
negative value within the reference
interval to a post-fight
positive value was 27.6 percent
of the fighters however
when we compare that to the significant
rcv
values we observed that 49.4 percent of
the fighters
now had positive changes and the same
thing occurred with the s 100 protein 54
were flagged as positive based on the
reference interval alone
whereas using the rcv calculation
we observed 86.2 percent who were
positive
so again this highlights the fact that
the use of the reference change value
can allow for better detection and
interpretation of positive test results
one of the limitations currently of the
biomarker tests
that we have in use
i'll finish with a few concluding
remarks based on what we have looked at
in this presentation today
first correctly identifying acute mild
traumatic brain injury
remains a continuous clinical challenge
there are diagnostic challenges of the
observational and functional tests
many of these rely on clinicians
subjective assessment
such as the glasgow coma score reading
ct scans often are negative in mild
concussion injury
serum biomarker testing offers
additional tools for the clinician
diversity of brain derived protein
biomarkers have gained increased
attention in the field
these are released into the peripheral
blood after damage to neuronal cells and
it's usually a
transient increase went back to baseline
in roughly 72 hours as we have observed
and current biomarker tests exhibit low
false negative rates or high clinical
sensitivity
but unfortunately suffer from poor
clinical specificity
therefore the serial sampling strategy
may allow for improved diagnostic
accuracy
that strategy compared the result change
between the last two tests
that the patient had to interpret as
positive or negative
and this is based on comparing to the 95
percent
significance level or reference change
value based on biological variation
estimates
for the test
thank you for attending and listening to
this presentation
on clinical utility of concussion injury
biomarkers
if i can help answer any questions don't
hesitate to contact me
at my email address provided here